he is the epitome of pure unadulterated
evil the mastermind guru with the
swastika on his forehead in the wild
crazed look in his eyes he is
responsible for one of the most heinous
crimes of our time controlling his
minions like puppeteer in this week's
biographic s-- we're looking into the
dark and disturbing story of Charles
Manson
[Music]
Charles Mills Manson was born on
November the twelfth nineteen thirty
four to sixteen year old Kathleen Maddox
and a 24 year old transient laborer
known only as Colonel Scott Kathleen was
a promiscuous teenager who drank too
much and earned money to fuel her habits
by selling her body the baby always
known as no name Maddox for the first
few weeks of life until his mother
seemed to settle on Charlie he never
knew his father he cleared out as soon
as he heard that Kathleen was pregnant
Kathleen was too young to mature and
unpredictable to provide a stable
environments for a young child she
appeared to have no maternal instinct
and would leave the child to fend for
himself while she went off on one of her
benders as an adult
Charlie often related that his mother
was once in a cafe with him on her knee
when the waitress offered to buy the
baby from her Kathleen's asking price
was a picture of the Aaron's having
consumed it she simply walked out and
left Charlie to the woman according to
Charlie his uncle took four days to
track him down and return him home when
Charlie was six years old his mother and
uncle decided to rob a gas station they
were both caught convicted and sent for
five years to Moundsville state prison
the boy was put into the care of his
strictly religious grandparents but
after a few months he went to live with
his aunt and uncle in West Virginia the
environments was very different to
anything Charlie had previously known
his aunt's unlike his sister was
regimented and disciplines she was also
strictly religious her husband's bill
was even more fervent in his faith than
his wife a strict disciplinarian he
considered Charlie to be a sissy on the
first day of school he send the boy to
class in a dress in order to teach him
how to fight
Charlie soon adapted to this very
different kind of life and actually grew
to enjoy his new regimented routine the
two years between six and eight would
prove to be some of the most stable of
his young life but then his mother was
released from prison and immediately
took him back Kathleen was more unstable
than ever she preferred a life of
promiscuity
and alcohol abuse to maternal domestic
city constantly in trouble with the
lorentz with no money for food and bored
they constantly moved around the Midwest
at the age of nine
Charlie dropped out of school the
transient life that he was forced to
live shapes the type of boy that Charlie
would become he kept to himself living
his life through his imagination he was
constantly watching taking
things in and dreaming of a future free
there's no hope mother
he also learns how to become a very
accomplished thief at age nine charlie
was caught stealing and sent a reform
school
three years later he was caught again
this time he was packed off to the jabal
school for boys in Indiana before he was
taken away Kathleen promised to visit
him often
of course they she never did just ten
months into his incarceration
Charlie escaped he robbed a grocery
store to get some money and went that
ran out he stole other things including
a bicycle he got caught in the act of
making off with the bike and soon found
himself back in confinement this time he
was sent to Indiana juvenile Center
that's after just two days he stole some
cutters and freed not in himself but
thirty other boys this time the escaped
young felon stole not a bike but rather
a car but the 13 year old could hardly
see over the steering wheel and was
apprehended within hours of his escape
when he ended up in juvenile court he
was surprised to see his mother his
spirits were dashed however when she
testified that she would not take him in
the somewhat sympathetic judge sent
Charlie to father Flanagan's boy's town
but the stay here it was almost too
short as his last incarceration after
his four days he ran off with another
young offender
Blackie Nelson they stole a car which
they subsequently crashed still on they
made their way to the hem of Blackie's
uncle a world war two veteran and an
underworld figure who gave the young
hoodlums free board and food in exchange
for the proceeds from armed robberies
that he had them commit during their
third robbery the two boys were caught
this time Charlie was sent to the
Indiana School for Boys in Plainfield
here he stayed for three years Charlie
would later claim that his small stature
led him to being constantly raped and
sodomized by other inmates as well as by
the school employees he also recalls
that he was constantly picked on by the
guards who would continually find fault
with him beating him with leather straps
and wooden clubs
[Music]
one night after being gang-raped by her
group of older boys he beat one of his
attackers two just short of the point of
death with an iron bar as the boy lay
sleeping Charlie then placed the iron
bar under the bed of one of the other
attackers successfully implicating him
in the attack
Charlie was exhibiting a trait that
would characterize his personality as an
adult this was that he would hold his
anger in for a time only for it to
explode later in an orgy of violence
over the three years he spent at
Plainfield Charley escaped no less than
18 times he was returned every time
though and in March of 1951 his sentence
was increased and he was sent to a
minimum-security institution this was
the National Training School for wise in
Washington DC here things were very
different what Charlie had known at
Plainfield the facility was well-run the
boys were treated well and same genuine
focus was placed on rehabilitation
Charlie lighted there but he had no
interest in being rehabilitated he'd do
his time but then he'd get back out to
the life of crime that he knew was
waiting for him at around the age of 15
Charley was given a psychiatric
assessment he was found to be aggressive
antisocial and illiterate a caseworker
reported that the boy was severely
emotionally traumatized and in serious
need of psychiatric treatment it was
also noted that he has a higher than
normal aptitude for music on October the
24th 1951 Charley was transferred to the
National bridge honor camp in Petersburg
Virginia three months later just weeks
before his parole hearing he sodomized
another inmate while holding a razor
blade to his neck he was reclassified as
extremely dangerous and transferred to a
tougher high-security facility the
federal reformatory at Petersburg
Virginia after seven months of the
federal reformatory Charlie had racked
up eight major violations he was
classified as defiantly homosexual
dangerous and safe only under
supervision with assaultive tendencies
towards the end of 1952 he was sent to a
higher security facility still there to
the surprise of everybody he transformed
into a model prisoner he took lessons in
reading and math and began working in
the vehicle maintenance department on
January the 1st 1954 he was given a
Meritus Service Award for his scholastic
achievements his application to history
and his apparent change of attitude led
to Charlie being paroled on May the 8th
1954 he was put in the care of his aunt
and uncle but within a month Athene now
19 year old was back living with his
mother herself recently released from
prison six months after his release
charlie married a waitress by the name
of Rosalie Jean Wyllys
shortly thereafter a son Charles Manson
jr. was born Charlie worked as a low
income job augmenting his pay by
stealing cars he used one of those
stolen cars to me of his wife and baby
to Los Angeles the car had been taken
from Ohio and authorities were able to
track it down
Charlotte was charged with a federal
crime for taking the car across state
lines he was given five years probation
but when he failed to show up to a
subsequent hearing he was arrested with
his probation revoked Charlie was sent
for three years to the prison on
Terminal Island in San Pedro California
after being there a few months he was
informed that his wife was living with
another man two years later she obtained
a decree of divorce
in September of 1958 Charlie was
released on five years of parole he was
now extending his criminal earning
potential by becoming a pimp he had a
sixteen-year-old girl working for him
over the next year he roamed around
California and New Mexico committing
crimes and repeatedly coming across the
law in June of 1960 he fled to Texas
with a California warrant out for his
arrest when one of his girls was
arrested there for prostitution he was
picked up and returned to Los Angeles to
face a 10-year sentence for cashing a
forged Treasury check at the age of 26
he was sent to the US Penitentiary as
McNeil Islands Washington while serving
his sentence he learned to play the
guitar and became interested in
Scientology during his time at McNeil
Islands he also became obsessed with the
Beatles Charlie had an inflated
appreciation of his own musical talents
claiming that he would with the right
backing and training be even bigger than
the Beatles
Charlie became friends with an inmate by
the name of Alvin Karpis this former
public enemy number one was a former
member of the infamous Matt Barker gang
he told Charlie how to play the steel
guitar this further fueled his musical
obsession and in 1966 Charlie's prison
record noted that he spent most of his
free time writing songs accumulating 80
or 90 of them in a single year carpets
later commented on the Charlie that
he knew at that time he recalled that
Manson was a master manipulator of other
people prison authorities also noted
that he had a tremendous drive to call
attention to himself in June of 1966
Charlie was sent once against Terminal
Island this time in preparation for
early release when the day arrived on
March the 21st 1967 he had spent more
than half of his 32 years behind bars he
requested that the authorities let him
stay in jail but he was told that he had
to leave
and so it was that the five foot nothing
drifter with the penetrating stare and
gift of the gab wandered into the
haight-ashbury district of San Francisco
with $35 in his pocket and no plans
except for a desire to make it big in
the music business Charlie moved into an
apartment in Berkeley and made money by
panhandling before long he had gotten to
know a 23 year old assistant librarian
at UC Berkeley named Mary Brunner he
quickly won her over and moved into her
apartment
Branagh came under Charley's spell and
he convinced her to widen out the home
within a few months there were 18 young
women living with them Charlie
introduced Mary and the other girls to
drugs and before long Mary had quit her
job and become a devoted follower of
Manson the family was beginning to take
shape with his female entourage and his
guitar Charlie merged perfectly into the
hippie culture that was then in full
bloom in San Francisco he refined his
role as a spiritual master a guru as a
prophet he used mind control techniques
to get girls to do whatever he wanted
most of the girls he gathered around him
came from troubled backgrounds and
suffered from insecurities that left
them directly opened to Charlie's
manipulations as well as breaking down
their inhibitions with mind-control
techniques he used LSD and amphetamines
to control his ever-expanding harem
after about nine months living in and
around San Francisco Charlie began to
despair of the place it had he asserted
become too overrun with
african-americans and crime was rampant
of course that family were doing their
best to add to those crime statistics
they stole credit cards and used
counterfeit money to get what they need
it they also stole a big yellow bus and
painted it black
Charlie and his followers took to
traveling by bus down the California
coast line as far as Mexico and Texas
partying and committing more crimes
after 18 months of extended travel they
finally settled in Topanga Canyon their
Los Angeles in a two-story house it was
here that Charlie began gathering some
male members to the family the first was
a teenager named Bobby Bose a Lyle who
turned up one night for a party and then
stayed on as Charlie's right-hand man
what we had been staying with his music
teacher Gary Hinman not far from the
medicine home what were you recruited an
18 year old named Leslie Van Houten's of
the family in June of 1968 around lap
time Charlie and some of the girls
traveled to Los Angeles where they met
up with a record executive at Universal
Studios former Jail friends Phil Kaufman
had arranged the meeting this was
Charlie's entry into the rich Jet Set
crowd and he turned on all of his charm
to make a good impression
soon the family were rubbing shoulders
with the rich and famous at posh parties
in the Hollywood Hills in the late
spring of 1968 Beach Boys drummer Dennis
Wilson was driving away from Malibu
beach when he happened to pick up two
hitchhikers the girls were part of the
Manson family and they quickly agreed to
go back to his Beverly Hills home the
three made love that afternoon and
Wilson left for a recording session
promising to return later to take up
where they left off when Wilson returned
home in the early hours of the following
morning he was surprised to see that a
full-scale party was underway he was
greeted in the driveway by a short man
with a scraggly beard who approached him
dropped to his knees and began kissing
his feet the girls who Dennis had met
earlier came running out declaring this
is the guy we were telling you about
this is Charlie inside his home Wilson
found 12 more women most of them topless
lying around and smoking pot Manson told
him that the girls were all there for
Wilson's pleasure
Wilson was impressed with the sway that
Charlie held over the women he welcomes
the family with open arms and his fame
became the regular venue for Charlie
orchestrated orgies Wilson calls Manson
the wizard and began inviting
influential showbiz friends to come and
meet him Dennis also allowed Charlie to
use anything he wanted his Ferrari or
rolls-royce and all the food and drink
and drugs that he or his groupies wanted
eventually Wilson's manager became fed
up with the influence and expense that
Manson was having on his clients and
Charlie and the girls were ordered out
of the mansion
rimas were also spreading of the
children of the rich and
as being given drugs and having sex
under Charlie's Direction suddenly the
door to the Hollywood elite lifestyle it
was slammed shut
Charlie's planned for music career was
also shut down this caused a familiar
buildup of jealousy anger and rage that
would inevitably find expression in
violence
Manson managed to convince the owner of
a former western movie set the spawn
Rajan chance would not far from Topanga
Canyon to allow the family to live in
the abandoned property the family now
moved to the ranch getting by by
stealing and scavenging Charlie took to
quoting the Bible Tom Lee members as
they gathered round bonfire during the
evenings he also interpreted Beatles
songs explaining that the lyrics were
directed towards them he was obsessed
with one song helter skelter telling his
followers that the song envisions an
apocalypse brought on by a race war of
blacks killing whites the blacks would
win he said but it would then turns a
Manson to lead the new world for Charlie
however the Revolution was taking too
long he wanted it to happen immediately
he began preparing family members for a
series of actions that would precipitate
the black uprising the first step would
be to release an album of music that
would contain subtle messages that would
ferment the black revolution on May the
8th 1969 Terry Melcher a producer who
had met Charlie through Dennis Wilson
arrived at spawn ranch to listen to
Charlie and the girls sing Mel Jarrett
made promises but never followed through
on them on the 25th of July 1969
Charlie ordered Bobby Beausoleil almonds
to women to the home of Gary Hinzman the
music teacher whom Bobby used to live
with Manson had heard that Hindman had
inherited $20,000 and he wanted us
Hinzman refused to hand over the money
Charlie was called and soon arrived
after screaming as him Charlie pulled
out a sword and cut off his ear Charlie
then left with instructions to get the
money or kill the man after three days
Bobby stabbed his former teacher to
death before leaving he and the girls
wrote the words political piggy on the
wall along with a panther paw in red to
lay the blame on the Black Panther
movement
Bobby Boesel L was arrested for murder
on August the 6th 1969 after being
caught driving around in Hinman's car
Manson was now ready to get his revenge
on Terry Melcher the record producer who
had let him down
on the evening of the 8th of August he
directed followers tax
Watson Linda Kasabian Susan Atkins and
Patricia KRENWINKEL to the house where
he believed to not sure was living with
instructions to totally destroy everyone
in it making it as gruesome as possible
the house was located at one zero zero
five zero Cielo Drive but Melcher didn't
live there anymore
it was now occupied by a famous director
Roman Polanski and his beautiful
eight-month pregnant wife Sharon Tate
that night Polanski was in Europe on a
film project his wife was entertaining
guests at the property hairdresser Jay
Sebring screenwriter of voytek frykowski
and coffee Empire heiress abigail folger
arriving at the property around midnight
Watson climbed to telephone pole near
the Hazen's cut the phone line the car
was then back to the bottom of a hill
that led to the house and the murder
team walked up to find the victims
Watson thought the gate might be
electrified so he into the girls climbed
a brushy embankment to get onto the
grounds just then car headlights came up
from further up on the property or
during the woman's a lie down in the
bushes Watson approached the vehicle and
levelled his 22 caliber rifle at the
driver that was 18 year-old Steven
parent Watson first slashed him with a
knife and then shot him four times in
the chest
Watson then ordered Linda Kasabian to
keep watch down by the gate he and the
other two women made their way into the
house the occupants were quickly
gathered together in the lounge when
asked by free Kowski who they were
Watson replied I'm the devil and I'm
here to do the devil's work
Watson then began to tie the heavily
pregnant Sharon Tate and Jay Sebring
together by their necks with rope had
brought and slung over a beam when she
brings protested over the rough handling
of Sharon Watson shot him and then
stabbed him several times meanwhile for
Kowski began struggling with Susan
Atkins who repeatedly stabbed him in the
legs and torso still frykowski managed
to get to the front door
seeing this Watson rushed after him
meeting up with him on the porch and
smashing his head with gun bus before
shooting him twice alle go for go had
managed to escape out onto the yard she
was chased by Patricia KRENWINKEL who
tackled her and then stabbed her to
death
the only remaining victim was now Sharon
Tate as she lay on the lounge room floor
with a wraparound and they actually
begged to be able to live long enough to
have her child but a police were ignored
and either Watkins or Atkins stabbed her
repeatedly including in the abdomen
until both she and
on baby we're debt remembering Manson's
instructions to leave a sign on the
walls
Atkins wrote the word Pig with Tate's
blood the very next day the family
struck again this time the victims were
Leno and Rosemarie LeBlanc are unhappy
with the messiness of the previous
night's killings this time Charlie went
with the group to show them how it was
done different accounts have been given
about the exact happenings that night
but we do know that Manson was in the
house and that he orchestrated the tying
up of the couple he then left with the
orders that the couple be killed before
leaving the words war rise death to pigs
and helter skelter were written with the
blood of the victims on the walls and
the refrigerator door the murders caused
a huge panic hollywood's the pressure
was now on to solve the heinous crimes
the police got nowhere until they
finally links the Hinman murder to the
tape love blanca killings they knew that
bobby Beausoleil all had lived with a
group of hippies at spawn ranch so they
decided to pay the ranch a visit Bobby's
girlfriend had told police that Charlie
Manson the hippie guru had ordered the
killing of Henman still there was no
evidence linking the group to the Layton
murders then in October 24 men's and
family members including Charlie were
arrested on charges of arson and grand
theft Susan Atkins was also taken into
custody and it was she who first began
to spill the beans she bragged to a
cellmate without killing Sharon Tate
giving a detailed account sent
implicating Charlie as the mastermind
about the same time police interviewed a
member of the straight satan's
motorcycle gang who was a Madison
acquaintance he told them the Manson had
recently been bragging about knocking
off five people the first piece of
physical evidence was the fingerprints
of Patricia Wren Winkle that was found
on Sharon Tate's bedroom door when other
pieces of physical evidence were
recovered the police were ready to send
the case to court
Manson and the four people who had
committed the tate-labianca murders were
found guilty and sentenced to death
these penalties however they would never
be imposed in 1972 the California
Supreme Court declared the state's death
penalty law unconstitutional and since
death sentence was commuted to life
imprisonment
Charles Manson died on November the 19th
2017 of cardiac arrest having spent
nearly 50 years behind bars for his
orchestrating of the crimes that shook
the world in 1969 he was 83 years of age
so I really hope you enjoyed their video
if you did don't forget to subscribe to
this channel for brand new biographies
every Monday and every Thursday also
I've got another channel it's called top
tens on that channel as you might guess
from the name we look at all sorts of
interesting top 10 so you can check it
out through the link on the screen now
but if you're looking for something else
to watch right now why not check out a
biography from the archives or a top
tens video over there on the right and
as always thank you for watching